whether they broke things off quickly or
they're still happily married with five
kids these fictional relatives ended up
in very real relationships
Anna Kendrick and Bill Hader play the
adult children of Santa Claus Who Saved
Christmas in the 2019 Disney plus
holiday movie Noel this stent as festive
movie siblings led to a romantic
relationship off the screen A source
told US Weekly Bill and Anna clicked
right away they dig each other's sense
of humor The Source made sure to clarify
that nothing happened between the two
until they were both single at the same
time hater got a divorce from his wife
Maggie Carey in 2018 and before dating
Kendrick he had a relationship with
Rachel Bilson his co-star in the to-do
list in January 2022 sources revealed
that Kendrick and hater were dating and
had been keeping their relationship
under wraps for under a year according
to cosmopolitan's math Kendrick and
hater got together sometime between July
2020 and December 2020 with speculation
about the status of their relationship
Rife a sourceful to ET Bill and Anna are
in love and very happy in their
relationship and enjoying their time
together hater didn't respond to the
comments choosing to keep their
relationship private for the sake of his
daughters unfortunately things just
didn't last for these on-screen sibs
with ET reporting that the two broke up
in June 2022 it's unlikely that we'll
see Kendrick appear in any of haters
future projects lots of guest stars here
tonight could we ever see Anna Kendrick
as a guest star oh no way
10 years on Gilmore Girls Lauren Graham
took a small break from TV for taking on
the role of another single mom in the
comedy drama Parenthood Graham's Sarah
Braverman is the mom to Mae Whitman's
Amber and Miles heiser's Drew she also
shares the screen with 9-1-1 star Peter
Krause who plays her brother Adam the
two play siblings in the series but it
didn't stop them from falling in love in
real life Graham has her Gilmore Girls
TV mom Kelly Bishop to thank for
encouraging her to date Krause the pair
obviously had a natural chemistry but
Graham has said that they were both
hesitant to act on it because of past
unsuccessful relationships they'd had
with co-stars after having worked
together for a while on Parenthood
though they decided to take plunge
ultimately Graham felt that working in
the same industry actually ended up
being a benefit the actor told people
it's hard to explain to people when you
have a fancy job like being an actor
what is challenging about it so we just
kind of have that shorthand a shared
language which is helpful their
differences eventually caught up with
them and they ended up separating after
more than a decade together during their
relationship Graham took on an important
stepmotherly role in the life of
krause's son Roman something she plans
to continue even after their 2021
breakup
David Tennant has played some impressive
roles throughout his career including
Barty Crouch Jr and Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire kilgrave and Jessica
Jones and Crowley in good Omens of
course his most iconic role will always
be that of the 10th doctor in the BBC's
Doctor Who it was the role that kept on
giving it introduced him to Georgia
moffatt the woman who would eventually
become Mrs Georgia tenant there's just
one thing though
[Music]
hello Dad the fictional relation didn't
seem to bother them the pair started
dating in 2008 and they married at the
end of 2011. David Tennant admitted to
the independent because Doctor Who had
run through my life like a stick of rock
to end up marrying the daughter of one
of the doctors it all felt a bit stupid
there were a lot of things against it
Moffitt who is the real-life daughter of
Fifth Doctor actor Peter Davison didn't
give up on their connection and it all
worked out in the end tenant continued
you reach a point of your life when
you're looking for someone and it's sort
of chance which version of that perfect
partner ambles along as of 2023 the
actors are still happily married and
share five kids together including House
of the Dragons Thai tenant
Milo ventimilia starred in Heroes from
2006 to 2010 as Peter Petrelli who turns
out to be the uncle of Hayden
Panettiere's Claire Bennett their
familial status in the series didn't
stop their off-screen connection though
the pair dated from 2007 to 2009 just a
year after vintamilia had separated from
Alexis Bledel pennettiere had also
recently ended her two-year relationship
with Laguna Beach star Stephen Coletti a
family friend confirmed their
relationship in 2007 telling people
Hayden's mom adores Milo she thinks he's
so cute she tells her friends that he's
her boyfriend she's very proud to some
fans however the age Gap in their
relationship was controversial
pennettiere was just 18 when they began
dating while vintamilia was 29 at the
time vintamilia didn't want to Fan the
media flames of their relationship
denying anything romantic and claiming
they were just good friends bent Amelia
and Panettiere ended up staying together
for almost two years although they did
not publicly comment on their split
another source told people they lead
different Lifestyles he's 31 she's 19.
she still has growing up to do and he's
very low-key according to the outlet the
pair remained cordial and they continued
to work on Heroes together until the
show ended
Barry Williams and Maureen McCormick are
more often recognized as Greg and Marcia
two of the siblings from The Brady Bunch
which aired from 1969 to 1974 Tales of
their off-screen relationship are
Infamous and the pair have both been
open about their time together over the
years in fact McCormick and Williams
enjoyed their first kiss together while
shooting the first episode of season
four in Hawaii as the actors revealed
during an appearance on Watch What
Happens Live a scale of one to ten
ten wow
McCormick revealed in her book here's
the story surviving Marcia Brady and
finding my true voice there was so much
electricity between us that I felt the
hair on my arms stand up every time we
got close to each other I thought about
Barry even when I had other scenes with
other guys I used to ask myself how I
could ever look in eyes other than his
Liquid Blues and feel such love however
their intense Attraction did make it
difficult when filming a scene later in
season 4 in which the teen actors had to
sit on the bed together McCormick
admitted we couldn't keep our hands off
each other despite their strong feelings
the on off relationship between these
on-screen siblings didn't work it
eventually fizzled out with McCormick
saying that timing got in their way
there are no hard feelings though the
former couple are still close friends
decades after their split Emily VanCamp
and Chris Pratt are both known for
starring in the MCU with Van Camp
playing Shield agent Sharon Carter and
Pratt traversing the Galaxy as Star-Lord
but but over a decade before their
superhero Adventures the actors worked
together on the show Everwood playing
siblings Amy and bright Abbott and they
fell in love on set in 2006 Pratt
admitted that he felt a little weirded
out starting a romantic relationship
with his on-screen sister as did fans he
told TV Guide yeah we've pretty much
gotten used to the response of ew that's
weird the people who know us are happy
and probably expected it to happen
eventually but yeah every once in a
while we get that one person that's like
that's really creepy you just kissed
your sister Van Camp and Pratt
ultimately ignored the haters and let
their love Blossom dating from 2004 to
2007 before going their separate ways as
of 2023 Van Camp is happily married to
her revenge co-star Josh Bowman with
whom she shares a daughter meanwhile
Pratt also has three kids a son with his
ex Anna Faris and two daughters with his
wife Catherine Schwarzenegger before she
married Josh Bowman and after dating
Chris Pratt Emily VanCamp dated another
of her on-screen siblings her brothers
and sisters co-star Dave Anibal before
Annabelle met his now wife Odette during
the show's Fifth Season the pair dated
for over a year when the show kicks off
Van Kemp's character Rebecca is shown to
be the half-sister of Annabelle's
character Justin but this storyline was
later Changed by the series Creator Greg
Volante relanti told Entertainment
Weekly I looked like an idiot here were
two young people who didn't grow up with
each other didn't know each other but
they had this electricity there was
nothing I could do in the second season
of brothers and sisters Rebecca
discovers she's not a member of The
Walker Clan after all which leaves her
and Justin free to date the shocking
twist was a welcome storyline for the
real life couple Dan Camp told ew I'm
all for breaking boundaries but we
didn't need to get into incest I draw
the line at that regardless it didn't
last band camp and Annabelle called it
quits in 2008 but continued working
together until she Departed the series
in 2010. in 2006 Jennifer Carpenter and
Michael C Hall met on the set of Dexter
Paul played the titular Dexter Morgan
while Carpenter played his sister
Deborah at some point between their
first meeting and 2008 the pair got
together and their romance only
intensified culminating with a marriage
on New Year's Eve that year around that
time Carpenter told on-demand
entertainment we had a great base for
our relationship we see each other on a
day-to-day basis and you know I know him
and he knows me the fact that they
played siblings didn't seem to get in
the way or make things weird either
things got serious in 2009 when Hall was
diagnosed with Hodgkin's lymphoma and
Carpenter supported him until he reached
remission the pair seemed stronger than
ever but sadly it simply wasn't meant to
be they divorced in 2011 but continued
to play siblings on the show until it
ended in 2013 and they reunited for the
limited series sequel Dexter New Blood
Carpenter told today that they will
always have a close friendship saying
just because the marriage ended doesn't
mean the love isn't still there
Catherine Heigl goes by many names to a
lot of her fans she's the queen of
romantic comedies from the 2000s While
others will always see her as Izzy
Stevens from Gray's Anatomy before all
of that though she was Isabelle Evans in
the Sci-Fi drama Roswell from 1999 to
2002 alongside Shiri Appleby Brendan
fair and Jason bear bear played her
on-screen adopted brother Max Isabelle
and Max were close but not as close as
Heigl and bear who dated off-screen for
most of the show's run although they
largely kept their relationship out of
the public eye during that time there
was enough attention on the actors to
spark romance rumors before they split
in 2002 bear soon moved on from their
relationship after meeting fellow actor
Katie Strickland on the set of The
Grudge in 2004 they tied the knot in
2006 and welcomed the sun in 2020. Heigl
also got engaged in 2006. marrying
musician Josh Kelly the following year
they have three children
before she became a household name for
starring opposite Patrick Swayze in
Dirty Dancing Jennifer Gray played
Jeannie Bueller in the Beloved 80s teen
comedy Ferris Bueller's Day Off
alongside Matthew Broderick as Ferris
and Genie Roderick and gray portray a
tumultuous sibling relationship with
their relationship off-screen was much
less strained gray admitted in her
Memoir out of the corner I was as
surprised as anyone when our
relationship morphed from on-screen
sibling rivalry to off-screen illicit
Romance the couple did everything they
could to keep their romance Under Wraps
stealing away moments together on set
they were so enamored with each other
that they became engaged before filming
had even ended
oh kids
great later revealed that her career
defining role in Dirty Dancing took its
toll on their relationship admitting
that she felt unsupported by Broderick
at this point the couple was still
hiding their relationship but the truth
came tumbling out when they were
involved in a serious car crash in
Northern Ireland in 1987. this signaled
the beginning of the end for the couple
who called it quits the following year
without tying the knot Roderick
eventually went on to marry Sex in the
City Star Sarah Jessica Parker while
gray rebounded by getting engaged to
Johnny Depp they didn't end up together
in the end though as gray shared 19
years of marriage with Marvel star Clark
Gregg before announcing their separation
in 2020
[Music]
foreign